so let's come back to this guy this one
that we drew at the beginning what
function does that look like looks like
y equals x squared right great you've
restored my faith in my ability to graph
that's always a plus right you can
recognize that as y equals x squared so
let's consider consider that as our
function okay if this the parabola is
our f of X right well what will its
gradient function look like what will
happen is I try to expand this thing
well let's have a go
it's equal to now you notice this when
we're first introducing limits but I'm
going to remind you again this limit
thing here isn't just like ah it's a
coincidence is sort of not that
important it's super important it's the
difference between this guy and this guy
oops
it's the difference in a secant and
tangent we're interested in tangents
seconds are boring tended to cool so
that's why I write the limit and you
have to write it every time now that
I've written all that and set it up I
can have a look at this right-hand side
view but I notice I know what f of X is
so I don't have to write it with this
general notation anymore I can write it
in this case if f of X is x squared what
f of X plus h what will I do
yeah Decker ooh
yeah this is all that time we spent on
function notation right to remember if
you see that X plus h being the input
then all you do is the same thing that
the function does to everything which in
this case is squaring right what about
this guy we already know that's by
definition X square that's just a
straight substitution and that's over H
now you've had some practice evaluating
limits before right most of the time you
had to do some fancy algebra to try and
cancel things out because I can't just
put in H equals zero here because as we
pointed out integers the denominator so
what would you like me to do how could I
simplify this yeah this is easier to
expand into do don't forget to write the
limit again why we're a little bit why
are we writing on it it's because I'm
interested in the tangent not the secret
right so the limit as H approaches zero
of have a go x squared plus that's the
extension isn't it take away x squared
just some simple algebra but have a look
at the numerator what's this going to do
now it's going to happen on the new moon
yeah you've got X squares at the top and
they go in to cancel each other so what
you get left with on the numerator by
the way I'm going to write them it again
why am I going to write the limit again
because I'm interested in the changes
not the secant I'm going to keep asking
you until you tell me the limit as H
approaches zero of this
yeah look so that's an itch that look
okay so I factorized out why is it
useful to factorize out because now you
can see this canceling happening right
cancel cancel I'm almost there
I'm going to write the limit again why
am I going to write the limit it's
because I'm interested in the tangent
not the secret that's the difference
between these things okay so I'm going
to write the limit one last time
I've cancelled so now I'm left with this
but now I don't have the problem of an H
on the denominator rule now I can
actually see what happens when H
actually goes to zero
what's this equal to okay so what does
this mean go back to your original graph
this guy over here okay this is the
gradient function it takes in an x value
any x value like and what it will output
is a gradient let's just test this out
if f dash x equals 2x put in a value
like say x equals 1 x equals 1 right and
x equals 1 what's that equal to f dash
of 1 in fact that's the way I would
write it f dash of 1 is 2 times 1 right
so you see I'm just using the function
notation that I've used before so I'm
evaluating at 1 which tells you that the
gradient at that point is going to be 2
that make sense is this thing like a
reasonable number it's steep and it's
increasing right what about a number
like say or an x-coordinate rather of 0
what's the gradient function going to be
at that case it's going to be 2 times 0
which is 0
does that make sense what is the
gradient down here or what's the change
look like in fact you've already drawn
the tangent haven't you it's the it's
that x axis there which has a gradient
of surprise surprise 0 ok
so this thing that you've just done this
process here has a big important name we
call this first principles because if
you want to find out the gradient of any
function you come back to this
everything in calculus is built on this
idea and that's why you call it the
first principle it's kind of like the
foundation stone that everything over
the next one now is going to be real fun
okay okay do you have to prove this in
the test because at the moment we have
just introduced this idea and it's such
a big deal the short answer is yeah yeah
you do you'd have to be able to show
this process which is why I kept on
emphasizing to you like what are these
things like this is on the reference
sheet but I don't care if you remember
or not what I care about is if you
understand where this thing comes from
answer its the gradient right I need to
know do you understand where this thing
comes from and the answer is because
you're interested in the teacher not the
seeker right one last little thing an
issue of notation I've been doing
everything in function notation so far F
and F dash and all that kind of thing
okay but a very frequent way that you'll
see this written calls back to this idea
just idea here how many of you guys do
chemistry have any chemistry okay almost
everyone all right so you guys know if
you put like a arm I'm going I'm about
to reveal the fact that I did not do
chemistry so if you have an equation a
chemical equation a reaction right you
have something like ah I don't know h2o
plus tell me something that h2o
reactants
I don't know salt or something there you
go okay and then you have an error right
and then what's on the arrow what's on
top of the arrow I think I think often
you'll see one of these right which is
you are these yeah okay and then you'll
have something else the results from
there yeah okay now this is a Greek
letter Delta all that indicates or it's
meant to indicate in your chemical
equation is
change change Delta that's a capital
Delta that's a capital Delta
it's just equivalent to our letter D
right it's the fourth order wrong so
instead of writing change in Y and
change in X which lazy mathematicians
like as if I'm going to write those
eight letters 16 letters every time I
need to talk about it's a very important
concept our sole ad they just say well
let's just use the letter D because
that's the letter we used to change so
the change in Y divided by the change in
X is just another way of talking about
the gradient function
it's just rise over run okay